[Musique]
notre acea ce soir l'entrepreneur
nicolas duvernois est avec nous ce soir
et le professeur robert d'automne
bonsoir à vous deux enfin alors dans
l'ensemble est ce que la vision du
gouvernement fédéral pour protéger les
canadiens pour soutenir les canadiens
pour relancer l'économie vous semble
juste ou est ce qu on fait fausse route
robert d'automne d'abord je pense qu'on
peut pas être compris lorsqu'on vient à
supporter allez soyez où les entreprises
qui subissent des contrecoups de la
pandémie
moi je suis avec ces mesures le ch n'est
pas à l'aise le pci qui devient un
international par un vote soit 100
points parfaitement là et c'est
essentiel je pense qu'on a pris soin de
le faire devant ça va créer un déficit
structurel conjoncturel mais on a vu
hier dbrs quand même mais plus la cote
de crédit de ge canada à 3,11 qui très
bon remède à ce qui m'inquiète un peu
c'est lorsqu'on veut s'engager dans des
dépenses comme l'assurance médicaments
ont dit les sorte de garderie pour
enfants vont venir
absolument on va y revenir à cette liste
qui est quand même très longue
votre réaction nicolas mas dans la pile
dans la question il ya un mode très
important la vision je sais pas si une
vision ou si c'est que ce ramassis de
programmes invente un peu sur le banc
d'une table pour répondre à une demande
à une autre demande vraiment un match
est inquiet parce que quand il ya une
vision est claire nette et précise mais
on la comprend la city monde se pose la
question puis se demande depuis match
dans les plates-bandes des provinces
mais pourquoi certains programmes il
change trois fois les règles les balises
j'ai peur qu'une perte de contrôle dans
tous ces programmes là et il faudrait
une vision claire nette et précise mais
c'est ça est-ce que c'est elle tint
d'avoir toute une liste vous avez
mentionné les garderies robert
l'assurance médicaments
les compétences des provinces qui sont
un peu escamoté depuis quelques temps
est-ce que c'était le temps de faire
cette liste là quand un indice id de 400
milliards robert avant des visions mais
il faut se rappeler que tout cet
exercice l'a conduit hier sur l'exercice
électoral
c'est en vue de prochaines sélections
donc des promesses électorales ça fait
pas ça fait partie d'une vision
je suis d'accord avec ça il fait qu'est
comme je tenterai dire tantôt les
dépenses au des programmes d'ailleurs eu
par exemple au québec on en a déjà
l'assurance médicaments puis 24 ans on a
des centres de petite enfance depuis
vingt trois ans ça fonctionne très bien
j'ai trouvé mes prises à la latitude du
gouvernement sur le refus de principe de
transférer des fonds pour l'assistance
pour la santé est encore plus transpiré
toit de méprise a de nous dire comment
ils vont gérer un ensemble de ses achats
samedi en passant je pense que j'étais
monsieur legault j'appellerais monsieur
trudeau eu de 1900 comme j'ai exactement
ça a été un petit à petit en jeu depuis
quelques années quand je veux faire
entendre un petit extrait de jean yves
duclos le président du conseil du trésor
qui était notre invité hier
on y parlait de ce déficit de 340 3
milliards voici ce qu'il disait pis je
vous pose une question de colas ensuite
contrôler évidemment évidemment il y en
a 1 parce qu'on cible ou le haut sur le
contexte de l'urgence sanitaire et
économique
mais je peux aussi ajouter que au canada
ça fait ce puissant tant qu'on n'a pas
vu un ratio l'intérêt par rapport au
produit intérieur brut ou si faible que
celui qu'on a maintenant est ce qu'on a
le contrôle
nicolas surtout tenant compte que le
canada une excellente situation
financière est ce que le gouvernement
vous croyez à le contrôle de ses
finances publiques
mais le contrôle je crois que c'est une
multitude de petits détails qui font en
sorte qu'à la fin on a le contrôle donc
la réponse claire et n'ont cependant
peut-être dans certains champs
d'expertisé ils ont compris mes skis et
ski et ski et ce qui me fait peur c'est
comme disait ma grand mère tant qu'il ya
de l'homme
l'omri donc avec tous ces programmes là
c'est sûr qu'il va en avoir 3 4 et même
plus qui vont profiter de ces boules ou
paul comme on puisse diriger parce qu'on
est de ceux qui ont pas vraiment besoin
et j'ai peur que des abus que la fraude
ayant note déjà d'ailleurs est juste
surtout peur que ça nuit iscariote
roanne on va donner c'est comme si ça
nuit à la relance économique
un moment donné il faut il dit mais
juste c'est comme une recette quand je
vais sur ricardo la bmoi ainsi jamais
trop ainsi au lieu d'une part si ça
goûte pas que ça devrait goûter gestion
kennedy liste interminable de priorité
robert est rien pour l'industrie la plus
importante du canada est ce que ça vous
choque vous que le mot pétrole
n'apparaissent pas dans le discours de
6000 7000 mon iphone chaque fois et ça
me surprend pas non plus faut dire que
monsieur trudeau a l'habitude de parler
de pétrole dans l'ouest de parler de
nous donner énergies nouvelles dans
l'est alors quand tu t'adresses à
l'union nippon n'a pas c'est clair je
mets à utiliser des très bons mots comme
transition écologique environnementale
mais ça veut rien dire parce que
pourquoi ça dynamise il n'y a pas de la
substance à rien ça d'abord pour
attendre aussi le budget moi je suis
donné une chance des beaux principes
je suis d'accord aussi avec le fait que
pour faire attention aujourd'hui jeune
suspect avec des chefs d'entreprise un
chef d'entreprise qui cherchent à 50 ans
pourront y travailler dans un centre de
distribution
un autre chercheur 1000 employés dans le
secteur a crû le menteur un secteur de
la fabrication est drôle du matin
donc il n'y a quand même je suis
d'accord ce qu'on aide on supporte les
gens qui en ont besoin
il faut faire attention aux que cette
générosité la nuit ce poids des
entreprises qui heureusement ne
subissent pas les contrecoups de mais là
le gouvernement doit quand même encore
aider des gens parce qu'il manque un
million cent mille emplois qui n'ont pas
été récupérées beaucoup de gens qui ont
vu leurs revenus baisser
nicolas la subvention salariale repoussé
jusqu'à l'été prochain prolongé jusqu'à
l'été prochain est ce que c'est une
bonne chose
oui et non pour ceux qui en ont vraiment
créé
le monde besoin bien sûr que c'est super
important et c'est le rôle du
gouvernement d'ailleurs devenir entend
leur aide
mais encore une fois je retourne
toujours dans les excès je retombe dans
dalida les chansons elle avait une
chanson qu'ils aient des paroles des
paroles des parodies un moment donné va
falloir des actions il va falloir aussi
tranchée il va falloir à mettre des
balises et avoir des personnes qui
respectent qui font en sorte de faire
respecter les règles qu'on s'est posé
des personnes responsables et qui une
impunité qui qui doivent donner des
comptes si on peut juste flopée de
l'argent comme ça et puis spiric tout va
aller bien kumba yala dans le monde d'en
haut l'ont peut-être avoue robert
je pense que les millions d'emplois
c'est un vrai objectif
mais celui qui nous suit qui vont
permettre de le réaliser c'est les
directeurs de la santé publique des
provinces donc moins capables de l'udps
et les restrictions qui sont causés par
la pandémie
et ça ça dépend évidemment de deux
choses la discipline la population et
deuxièmement l'apparition d'un véhicule
de vaccins oui exactement et donc ça va
prendre encore un peu de patience de
toute évidence robert nicolas merci
beaucoup